Speaker 1: It is so obvious that former Republican
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie is by far
the best Republican candidate running for
president this year.
He is, at least for now, not doing the anti-woke
stuff.
He's willing to go after failed twice, impeached
once indicted former President Donald Trump.
He sounds like a normal person, although we
obviously have policy disagreements and the
MAGA people don't want him.
We are going to look at clips of Chris Christie's
town hall that he did yesterday announcing
his candidacy running against Trump.
And it's after watching this town hall.
It's clearer than ever to me.
If I were voting in the Republican primary,
if I knew a Republican would be president,
it would be Chris Christie that I would support.
And this is not about glorifying or glamorizing
the guy.
But he's willing to tell what should be pretty
uncontroversial truths.
He doesn't equivocate when he's asked about
Trump and say, well, I'm not talking.
I'm here focused on me, not on Trump.
No, he understands you've got to go against
Trump.
And this was a very solid town hall.
If more Republicans were like Chris Christie,
we would have a much better country than we
do with people like Trump and Marjorie Taylor
GREENE and Lauren Boebert and these sorts
of lunatics.
Here's Chris Christie going right after Trump.
He's not afraid.
Speaker 3: A lonely self consumed.
Self-serving.
Mirror hog.
He is not a leader.
Well, let me be clear.
In case I have not been already the person
I am talking about.
Who is obsessed with the mirror.
Who never admits a mistake.
Who never admits a fault.
And who always find someone else.
And something else to blame for whatever goes
wrong but finds every reason to take credit
for anything that goes right.
Is Donald Trump.
And if we don't have that conversation with
you.
We don't deserve.
To ask for your vote.
Speaker 1: I completely agree.
Nikki Haley won't even say anything other
than, Well, I'm a woman and I'm younger and
I'm a person of color.
And Tim Scott says there's going to be a contrast,
but I'm not making this about other candidates.
Now, an audience member during this town hall
asked Chris Christie.
If Trump's indicted and you're president,
will you pardon him?
When DeSantis was asked about this.
He basically said yes.
Chris Christie, on the other hand, is saying
almost certainly not with a little bit of
equivocation, but almost certainly not.
Speaker 3: If Donald Trump is indicted.
Speaker 4: And you become president.
Speaker 3: Will you pardon him?
Well, I. I have to tell you the truth.
I can't completely answer that until I know
what he was charged with and convicted of.
Okay, So but but I'm not going to dodge the
answer.
Okay.
But I will tell you, as a prosecutor, if I
believe someone has gotten a full and fair
trial in front of a jury of their peers and
especially someone in public life who committed
those crimes when they held a public trust,
I can't imagine pardoning them.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So I'm hearing that is almost certainly not
not a perfect answer, but a thousand times
better than the answer given by Ron DeSantis.
Chris Christie did had on face what he considers
the biggest mistake of his political career,
which was that some of the people working
for him had that insane situation where they
diverted traffic off the George Washington
Bridge as political punishment, I believe
it was to the mayor of Fort Lee, New Jersey,
although I don't now remember 100%.
Obviously, Chris Christie is going to minimize
the degree to which he was the one at fault,
but he's taking responsibility.
I just wish more Republicans talked to this
directly because they just you can't get a
straight answer out of almost any of these
clowns.
Speaker 3: The biggest mistake I made public
life was I put a few people into a position
of authority at the Port Authority of New
York and New Jersey, who went on a frolicking
detour to divert traffic off the George Washington
Bridge without telling me, without me knowing
anything about it.
They used my power and my authority to play
a fraternity prank, and it costs me a lot.
It cost me credibility.
It humiliated me publicly.
And I should have never put those people in
that position.
The biggest mistake I made.
There you go.
Biggest mistake.
Speaker 1: Chris Christie also addressing
the claim by Donald Trump that if he were
president, he would end the Russia Ukraine
war in 24 hours.
Chris Christie pointing out the way he would
end it is by giving everything to Russia.
Speaker 3: And now I heard him say if we made
it president again, he would settle the Ukraine
war in 24 hours.
Did you hear that one?
That's a beauty.
That's really in a career of complete falsehoods
that makes the top five.
But let's give him the benefit of the doubt.
Let's say Donald Trump could settle it in
24 hours.
Let me tell you how he would.
He'd give Ukraine to Russia and he said it.
He said it on television.
He said, let's see it.
And he said, well, Russia's a winner with
Ukraine anyway.
So what's the difference?
That's how it settled in 24 hours.
He calls Alinsky and say, Hey, guess what?
Time to raise the Russian flag up on the pole.
We're out of here.
Speaker 1: There are no other Republican candidates
willing to say this.
They just aren't willing to do it, whether
they believe it or not, I don't know.
But Chris Christie is at least willing to
say this stuff.
And it is abundantly clear to me that there
is going to be one guy on the stage with Trump
if they get that far who is not going to be
pulling punches.
Everybody else is pulling punches.
Chris Christie is not pulling punches.
Here is Chris Christie breaking out the Trump
impression on day one of his campaign.
Speaker 3: It was a mistake in 2016 not to
confront Donald Trump early.
True, because I knew that so much of what
he said was complete baloney.
Like I knew it.
I am going to build the greatest, most wonderful
wall across the entire Mexico border, and
Mexico is going to pay for it.
Well, like I knew as someone who had governed
that that was complete bull, but I was like,
Yeah, people aren't going to believe that.
They're not going to believe that mistake.
It was a mistake.
Speaker 1: And he's completely correct.
And he points out other bogus claims that
Trump has made.
He talks about debt and deficit here.
And again, this isn't the Chris Christie cheerleading
segment.
It's there is something notably different
about Chris Christie compared to all the other
candidates and how they are relating to the
issues.
Notice that there isn't any anti-woke stuff
here.
At least he's talking about moderately real
issues.
Here he is about national debt and pointing
out Trump's lies there as well.
Speaker 3: Reason this is going to be different
this time, sir, is because at least one of
us.
Is going to call him on the fact that eight
years ago he stood on the stage in New Hampshire
and said he was going to balance the budget
in four years.
And he left with the biggest deficit of any
president in American history.
He said he was going to eliminate the national
debt in eight years.
Speaker 1: Trump did say that.
Speaker 3: He added $3 trillion to the national
debt in four years.
Speaker 1: So a very, very strong town hall
overall.
It'll be interesting to see whether this moves
the needle at all in terms of polling, which
right now is not great for Chris Christie.
One last.
Clip from this.
Chris Christie made the claim during the town
hall that if Biden had been running against
someone different in 2020, Biden would have
lost that Biden was a poor candidate but won
because so many people so acutely dislike
Donald Trump.
And it's certainly possible that that is true.
It's possible.
Speaker 3: Let me be very clear.
I am going out there to take out Donald Trump.
But here's why I want to win and I don't want
him to win.
And guess what?
If you put the Santas and Haley and Pence.
And Tim Scott.
That's it.
I'll stop there.
A truth serum.
They tell you the same thing.
Here's the difference.
You have to put me on truth serum to tell
you.
Okay.
So that's why there are not multiple lanes
to the Republican nomination.
That is a political science professor's dream.
There is one thing.
Yep.
It's the Republican nomination and he's in
front of it.
And if you want to win, you better go right
through.
Because let me guarantee you something.
From knowing him for 22 years, everybody.
He had to go through me.
He's going to try to go through Ron and Nikki
and Tim and anybody else who stands in his
way.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Chris Christie gets it.
Chris Christie understands what's going on.
Trump's not a good candidate, but Trump is
leading the Republican nomination.
The path to the nomination is through Trump.
It's not taking your 2% like Nikki Haley or
sorry, 4% like Nikki Haley, or 2% like Tim
Scott.
And just talking about how you're going to
be positive and whatever the path is through
Trump.
And the question is whether Chris Christie
will be able to do it.
I don't know.
I'm curious to see what polling looks like
in two weeks.
In the meantime, all sorts of people reacting
to Chris Christie's candidacy just by talking
about his weight.